how many times do you see filmmakers
make a film
with zero attention to their
distribution plan
most of the time almost all of the time
actually
yeah i mean that's most of what
i consult on i mean almost all my
consulting is
let's talk about how you're going to
sell the movie and hopefully
they call me to consult before they make
the movie
and you know people say like why are we
talking about this and i said because
the first question asked is do you want
to make money with your movie do you
have an intention to sell your movie for
money
if they say no then i said you know we
don't have to have this conversation we
can just talk about artistic stuff if
you want
but if the answer is yes then then we
talk about marketing and distribution
long before we talk about production and
most filmmakers don't talk about it
for two reasons one three reasons one is
they don't think to talk about it you
know they don't really know
that that's a question that you have to
ask before the fact
two is they can't stand the whole
distribution business i mean it's just
such a turn off you know because it's
not what they do they make movies they
don't sell movies you know and three is
it's you know it's something it's almost
denial because
like i said you got to spend a lot of
money on marketing and it's a whole
business and everything like that and
that might you know destroy the whole
project if i said hey
go raise as much money for marketing as
you are for production
that's like a non-starter but it
shouldn't be
because that's the business do most
people contact you
after the fact after they've tried to
get this film out
you know they've already had their party
they've already had their festivals run
yeah that yes they do and that's because
they didn't know to contact me before
now
a lot a lot of the newer clients are
starting to
contact me first because they're
watching some of my videos and and some
of my materials and stuff and a lot of
people on the internet are talking about
that
but not not too many people are doing it
they're just going through the motions
and talking about it because
how many indie filmmakers you know who
actually started their career in
distribution
because like like i said it's crazy to
go from
distribution to production i mean i can
see going the other way around
i mean it's crazy it's just you know
it's very rare that that would happen
um so it's kind of unique that i would
understand distribution and have a
really soft spot for
indie filmmakers because i am one of
them and like
the thing one of the things i enjoy the
most is almost like and
this maybe is the legal part of me
kicking in is
i love to defend an indie filmmaker in a
distribution negotiation
i love that it's my favorite thing i
love to sit beside them and listen to
the distributor
explain how the deal is going to work
and then
kind of pull them aside and explain how
the deal really works
and what really is going to go on and
then sometimes they'll say okay jeff you
say it because i won't say it properly
or sometimes i won't even be in the room
they'll call me or whatever or they'll
send me their contract or deal memo
and then i love to renegotiate the deal
and say
okay how about this let me give you a
perfect example okay
so every distributor if you've ever been
in one of these distributions you're an
indie filmmaker just made
a feature it's good feature you know
it's a good feature
and you want to make money with it so
you're going to go you get lucky you get
into
you know say five distribution meetings
with reputable distributors
all right don't ask how they got there
and you do it okay
you get into the first meeting here's
how it goes and i'm gonna
shorten this okay it's a lot longer you
know pleasantries how are you that it is
a great film okay all right we're going
to make you a great offer
all right we're going to give you it's
going to be a 10-year
deal exclusively and
we're going to give you 200 000 minimum
guarantee
up front against um we're going to take
a 30
fee and 10 costs no they're
sorry they don't say cost we're going to
take a 30 fleet plus our costs
and we're going to give you 200 000 up
front sound good
sounds good i'll take it really okay
now you phone me now these they give you
the deal memo
they send it to me i say first question
how much did it cost you to make the
movie
800 thousand i said okay they're giving
you two hundred thousand i know but
they're gonna they
they also said they're gonna you know
they're the best in the
business and they're gonna generate two
million dollars in sales
they're going to take 30 so i'm going to
get 70 of 2 million
1.4 million and they gave me 200 000 up
front so i'm going to get another 1.2
million
so that's a good deal really good i said
okay what if they don't
oh but they said they would okay they
also
here's what i say so i say let me go in
and have a conversation
so i get there and i say okay ari you're
the distributor
are you the best in the business
absolutely we're the best and we've been
at 25 years we've sold 500 movies
we are the best good because i only want
to deal with the best i don't want to
deal with second-rate guys
i'm glad we're sitting here you're the
best i want to deal with you
you're here you're you're dealing with
the best great okay
what do you think you could sell on the
movie well we told we said we can do two
million dollars in sales and by the way
that's a low estimate we didn't want to
tell them we're probably going to do 5
million
but we want to be conservative because
we don't want to give the filmmakers you
know
like bad expectations but we can do two
till a million dollars in sales
gross sales on this really that's good
and it's likely going to be a lot more
but let's go with that number
i say fantastic you can take a 30 fee so
you're going to deliver
1.4 million dollars back right
you are the best and that's a low
estimate
why'd you only give them 200 000 up
front i got a i got a
this crazy idea you're the best you know
exactly what you're doing
and you're going to do 2 million dollars
in sales
with your eyes closed that's going to be
a walk in the park because you're
actually going to do more
you're going to generate 1.4 million how
about this why don't we just split the
difference and give us 700
000 up front as a minimum guarantee half
of what you're going to do
as a no-brainer and you're the best at
it oh no no we can't do that
why not well what if it doesn't sell of
course it's going to sell you just told
us it's going to sell for 2 million and
you told us you're the best
but what if it doesn't sell but no no
don't but i i don't want to deal with
somebody who's not going to sell it
you're the best that's why i'm here
and the two million is nothing like it's
it's a walk in the
those are your words not mine well but
maybe it might not sell well
then i don't want to deal with you
because you're not the best and you're
not telling me the right numbers
that's how a negotiation goes okay so
you're the distributor
what do you do do you give an extra 500
000 half of what your projection is or
do you stick to the 200 and walk away
from the deal
you likely stick to the 200 and walk
away from the deal why
because you know you're you're not going
to hit that number
if you knew darn well if you had those
sales in your pocket already
you'd give the 700 000 in a heartbeat
because you've already pre-sold it you
already know what to expect
and if and when you're in that situation
you can get that kind of deal
but most indie filmmakers will never be
in that situation they don't have that
kind of leverage
okay because they're new at the game and
they
one is they don't know what to ask for
so they would never have that kind of
conversation because that would be way
too
you know too aggressive okay then then
you get into costs
you said you're going to take your costs
how much your cost well they're going to
be around 10 to 12 percent for what well
we have
delivery and all this kind of stuff i
say show i need a delivery schedule i
need to know what it is
i want to cap you at 5 no no no no and
by the way 10 years
why do you need 10 years i mean how long
is it going to take you to sell you
could probably sell in
three years well you know just in case
all these just in cases i just spent
eight hundred thousand dollars making my
movie
i didn't get any just in cases from
anybody why do you need all these just
in cases
now the problem with what i'm telling
you is it's easy for me to say that
because
i did that for a living for i sat on the
other side of the table for 22 years so
i know exactly how that game is played
and everything like that
and i'm being you know a little cocky
about it right
you do that as a filmmaker they'll
escort you out of their office and
never want to do business with you
because you're pushing them too hard
but that's the way it's supposed to be
that's the true
deal and that's the true way a
negotiation should go in that situation
but they have
all the leverage so they don't go that
way unless
you got a really good film and if you
got a really good film
then you need to work it it just all
depends on
and do you know how you know if you have
a really good film whether they want it
or not
so you got to push that envelope a bit
you got to believe in yourself and in
your product and you got to push it
and you can't just take the first deal
they put on the table because it's
usually going to be a crappy deal
and you're going to end up losing a ton
of money because
in some ways you also have to assume
that you're not going to see another
penny after that minimum guarantee
unless you also build in there's lots of
stuff you have to build in performance
guarantees they have to
performance thresholds they have to hit
certain levels within certain time
frames otherwise that's a breach of the
contract
there's all this stuff they hate me the
distributors hate me because i'm one of
them
they don't even some of these new
distributors they don't even know some
of the questions that i
like some of the terms that i put in i
tuck them in and say like where'd this
come from
but you know what you get one shot at it
you're a filmmaker you put your heart so
this is why
i have a real soft spot for filmmakers
because
i know how much time effort and money
they put into the and the heart and soul
they put into making their film
then they walk into these meetings and
get railroaded
absolutely railroaded just because they
don't know what to ask
and how to ask for it and how to push
push the issue because they're too
scared to
lose the deal and so they end up taking
a really really bad deal
and in some ways it's better not to take
any deal and try for the next deal
now will the next deal come along maybe
maybe not but basically what you're
saying is
you've throwing it up in the air and
giving it away and and knowing that
you're never gonna like a bad deal is
not
worth taking unless you're totally
totally desperate
and there's no other deal to take then
you can take a bad deal but when you're
first starting out and you're getting in
and you have a good film you made a good
film
work it anyways listen
easier said than done i feel super
confident working because i
i know all the terms i know all this you
know what i got a better idea
call me and i'll work it for you okay i
will work the deal for you that's what i
like to do like as i said
one of my favorite things is helping
a inexperienced really good artistic but
inexperienced
filmmaker in terms of distribution
negotiate a deal
i like doing that you said performance
guarantee
that they have i know you said a minimum
guarantee which is called an
mg nmg yeah mg performance guarantee
what what does that entail
okay it's something i think i made up to
be honest with you
okay i made it up many years ago i gave
it a name but
people do it but but i do it a lot um
first of all let me just define minimum
guarantees so everybody understands
so you're going to get say 70 of the
revenue which maybe we can negotiate
down to
or up to 75 percent and that's called
royalties
or producer share some people in a
production in a distribution call it
could produce your share
or royalties okay that's what you're
going to get that's the producers
take revenue and then and a minimum
guarantee on mg
is what they will give you up front
against that so if you're going to get
1.4 million
total and they gave you 200 000 that was
your minimum guarantee
so now they're only going to give you
another 1.2 the first 200
000 that they earned they've already
paid you up front
that's a minimum guarantee okay a
performance
guarantee or performance threshold so i
built these into my contracts years ago
i'm giving away a really good trade
secret here so everybody pay attention
when i say this
all right you want to deal with a good
reputable distributor and as i said i
just played the game you're the best
right
if you're the best how long is it going
to take you to generate that million
dollars in sale
it's you say it's going to take you two
years
and i'm going to say why is it going to
take you so long you're in every market
you know every customer
you can make phone calls well it's
probably going to take a year but we
need to
have two years say how about this i'll
give you 18 months
and if you don't have 700 000 of
gross sales contracted and i get to see
the contracts you have to share them
with me
by 18 months from now then i have the
option
to terminate the contract we'll consider
that a technical breach and i
have it's my option to terminate because
you
are not performing at the level that you
just promised me you would perform at
that's what i call performance threshold
and i i built those in and a lot of
distributors say
sorry no deal because they're not
confident
they don't want to be held to that and i
say you want my film
that's i expect you to be able to do
what you say you're going to do
and that's my guarantee that you'll
that's my
out if you don't do it i'm not saying
i'm going to necessarily exercise it's
an option
so it's my option not yours i have an
exclusive option
to walk away from the deal and and at
that point there's
termination you know language okay i get
this you get this you know we
you know this is how it all resolves
itself and how
if they agreed to that term how would i
know
could i call up and and it would be they
have to part of that term is
they have to give you transparency and
visibility to the deals they've done
which they're supposed to do anyways
that's called reporting you're supposed
to have that because
they're reporting to you and on a new
distribution contract they're supposed
to report
they should report to you quarterly
every three months for the first two
years you should expect that
so it's not like you're not gonna have
visibility to that anyways
it's just what level you're going to hit
in your reporting
this is a serious serious distribution
term that
nobody really does that because they're
too scared to do it or
they haven't thought about it or or
distributors say no way
so most independent filmmakers they
don't want to rock the boat and they
don't know what they don't know
okay most independent filmmakers they
don't even want to get involved in this
this is like doing surgery you know like
you know a nurse doing surgery it's it's
just not what they do they don't want to
do it they don't take a chance they
don't want to get involved and they
can't stand the idea of doing it okay
secondly even if they were to get
involved they didn't go to medical they
didn't go
they didn't learn surgery so they don't
know what to do
even if they have the desire to do it
they don't know what to do
so they don't have the technical
know-how to know what to ask for
and it's not their fault they don't
teach it in film school
the only way to learn that is to
actually be in the in the business and
learn it the hard way
i didn't you know i didn't come into law
school and know that i had to work in
distribution it took me five years to
learn all this stuff
so is it reasonable to expect that a lot
of filmmakers will be taken advantage of
for their first
distribution deal it's not only
reasonable but it's probable
it's it's highly highly likely and it's
and i said on another podcast it's not
that the distributors are evil people
but they they're in business they're in
business to make the best deal that they
can make for themselves
and if the person on the other side
doesn't ask for the right things you
know it's not their obligation to put it
on the table
so they're dealing it's a little bit of
an unfair negotiation because they have
an advantage of
having more knowledge and more
experience than the person on the other
side
that's why sometimes it's good to go
into these negotiations with somebody
who knows what they're doing like a
lawyer or a consultant or something like
that
because even though you're going to pay
a fee for that you're going to end up
with a much better deal
and you're not going to get screwed so
it's not that they're omitting
information they're just not suggesting
that they're not putting it on the table
okay yeah okay i mean you know and
in some cases i will say they're
purposely not putting it on the table
because they know they don't have to
they're not being nice about it they're
not being
sympathetic knowing that the guy on the
other side knows nothing
sure they're just so excited most indie
filmmakers are
so excited to just have the the meeting
and then to get any deal that's usually
the case
they're just like just so eager to just
get any deal
which is too bad but it's the nature of
the beast unfortunately
you